Welcome everyone.
Uh, thank you for joining this session on
mastering model choice in Amazon Bedrock.
We're glad you're here.
Uh, how many of you, uh, are
overwhelmed by the number of AI
models available
when building AI applications?
Great, uh, and how many of your
organizations have a
systematic framework for picking out
models for AI applications?
All right, fewer hands there, great.
Well, we're here to help, uh.
We're gonna talk through a simple framework
that
you and your organization can use to identify
models, evaluate those models, and optimize them
for production based on the work we're doing with our
customers,
uh, at AWS.
I'm Scott Munson, principal worldwide
AI specialist with Amazon Bedrock team.
Along with me today are John Liu,
principal product manager with Amazon Bedrock,
and Brian Coe,
senior AI product manager
with Coin Market Cap.
So quick agenda, uh, we're gonna
start off by just an overview, kind of set the context. What
are the challenges that our customers are seeing
and, uh, how are we helping them
and then talk through the framework itself. So how do
we identify and evaluate
and optimize models
and then we'll have a chance to hear
from Brian
to uh how he's using this framework and his
with his team
to, uh, deploy AI applications
that are serving over 65 million monthly
active users.
So
Get a sense of the landscape. Uh, 2.19
million public models available in hugging Face
today. Uh, chatted with
the chief product officer of Hugging Face
yesterday. He said there's a new model every 10 seconds,
uh,
incredible pace, right? That adds up to about 4000
models per day.
That's just
publicly available open weight models. Uh,
add to that all the proprietary model
makers, Anthropic, Amazon, OpenAI,
all the rest.
Uh, we have so much choice. This
is in every modality.
Uh, text,
image,
video, audio, new modalities, there's
so much innovation,
um, it's an exciting time
to be building these applications
with AI
models, but
there's a little bit of a bottleneck. I mean, we're hearing from customers
that picking the model itself is actually a challenging,
uh, task.
So why is it challenging? What's the consequence of this?
What we're hearing is that the POCs matter
when you're building out an AI application for the first
time with your organization. You wanna make
sure that that's a successful
trial run. They're not all guaranteed to to be successful,
but it matters to our customers that they have
a a good win early on in this process.
And so, uh, this matters for the time
and labor spent, but also just the momentum and
organizational kind of reputational impact.
So it, it can be a tough loss if they pick the wrong
model for the job and build around that.
We're also hearing this
specific problem of no selection framework
to to work
through all the models uh with and so we're gonna
talk through that today of course
and the pace of innovation is challenging. If
it takes 4 weeks to
test out your models and pick the the one you like
and a better model came out yesterday, it's sort
of a challenging, uh,
environment to work in, so pace is important
to our customers.
And then of course uh any
customer facing application, any large organization
application needs to function at scale. So sometimes our
POCs aren't,
uh, optimized for the big production workloads and we
wanna make sure that our customers are successful
in that arena as well.
So Amazon Bedrock is uh
AWS's solution to provide
uh developers what they need
to focus on their developing of
applications and, and we can kind of provide the rest,
uh, you know, Bedrock has
a great selection of top models
uh that are kind of coming out continuously
and we're committed to providing great
model choices.
We optimize uh our inference
to make sure that our customers can
use this inference in a serverless manner so they can scale
up and scale down they can use different modes
of inference, um, they can balance the
requirements of their application without having to do all the deployment
of AI models themselves.
A lot of our customers are seeing success
by leveraging their data, so
that could be in the form of a rag knowledge-based
solution or it could be in, uh, model distillation,
uh, or fine tuning, uh, according
to their, their specific proprietary data.
And, um, of course
safety and responsibility are critical. So Amazon
Bedrock provides guardrails,
uh, along with other features that help our
customers ship their products with,
uh, with kind of confidence in the reliability
and, uh, responsibility of their AI
applications. And we're doing a lot with gentic
work. uh, this week we launched
a number of agent cop,
uh, capabilities that are very exciting to help you
seamlessly deploy and operate agents at
scale. To
go a bit further on, uh,
model, uh,
options themselves, we really do work with
top model providers and continue to expand
that number over time.
Uh, we think that's important. We're hearing
from our customers they want that choice of models,
so we're committed to, to giving them that
model evaluation tools are a critical
kind of counterpart with that to make sure that
customers know what the right model is
and. We also allow people
to import their own models. So if you fine tune
a model or have another model that you're interested in using,
um, we can
import that and through custom model import and
provide that inference, uh, along with the other
models available,
which is a big kind of convenience factor again letting us
handle that, uh, inference task for
customers.
And again, Bedrock has, uh,
this slide shows 13. We added 4
additional model providers this week. We launched models
from Google,
from Minimax,
from Nvidia, and from Moonshot,
uh, very exciting. We're over 80 models now
available on Amazon Bedrock.
Uh, we
really do, uh, hear from our customers and
are convinced that
us providing this inference for them,
this Bedrock service gives them the simplicity,
the scale.
And security that they need so they can just
focus on
their domain and their application development.
So
Great to have all those models. You still have to pick, uh,
some to use for your application and so this
is the model selection framework.
Uh, we've kind of pulled this from working with a lot
of customers and, and trying to simplify
it down so you can work with your stakeholders and kind of,
uh, understand easily what stage you're in.
Uh, this, the process itself is, is relatively
simple if you, uh, think about it in these terms.
First up, you identify candidate models so you look
at all these.
Options and filter them down. We'll go into
exactly how to do that in a moment.
Then you evaluate those models on your data
on your use case. This is really critical. Generalized
benchmarks
are not the greatest indicator
of what model is gonna be most performant to meet your
application's requirements.
And then we have another step to optimize
those models that might be
through breaking up the AI workload into multiple
models,
uh, to meet the performance requirements you
need or potentially through fine tuning,
uh, as well. So we'll talk through all that
today. Um,
and to help kind of keep us grounded, we're gonna
use this, uh, use case to help
understand the process. So we've got a financial crimes
investigation agent
scenario. This is one that our
customers have built that we've talked, uh,
know what this looks like.
Um, in this case, uh, you know, a
financial institution,
something gets flagged for potential financial crime,
uh, they still are a human review
process required,
so these analysts are manually reviewing a
lot of documents, transaction data.
It's time intensive work and they
want to accelerate this workflow
for them. The requirements we're looking
at for this application would be to
process structured and unstructured data.
We wanna generate
really accurate, concise summaries.
Um, this is a large scale, uh,
and so we're looking at about 5 billion tokens per day.
So we wanna make sure we're
keeping that in mind as we're picking out
the models we wanna use. And then of course security is
essential.
Um, the goal here would be to hit 20%
efficiency for these humans
workload and, and be able to work more quickly.
So,
the identification stage, um, I'll kinda
go into more detail on this.
Put simply, we're gonna filter out all the models
that are relevant by modality and just consider
the ones that are relevant for our use case.
Next up we'll look at all those benchmarks. They are valuable.
There is utility there, especially the
more detailed benchmarks, and then
considering benchmarks alongside other metrics that you
care about.
And finally we'll look at some differentiated capabilities.
There's so much innovation.
There's a lot of categories of models, but there's a few
that I wanna highlight that really we're seeing
matter for application success.
So first up, modality. This one's relatively simple.
What's the input type that the model
can ingest and what's the output type
that it, uh, that it
provides?
Um, huge amount of text data, of course,
in business.
A lot of these models were initially started there, so
we've got some great options within text,
but we're seeing, uh, you know, a lot of great use cases
developed with an image input,
video, audio, as well as the outputs,
uh, of all of those modalities. So
step one,
just look at the models that are relevant for your use case.
And here's a little view on what's available in Bedrock,
uh, bi-modality this can be helpful, right?
A lot of
great models available within the text category,
uh, multimodal input, so those are often text plus
image, uh,
also some video understanding available,
um, multi-modal output, and then
embeddings, a lot of growth in those
areas. We're launching new models,
uh, all the time and,
uh, meeting more of our customers' needs that way.
So we've got it filtered by modality. Now let's think
about uh.
A way to kind of compare quickly.
Artificial analysis is a very popular third
party resource.
They provide an index and metrics
for
a huge range of models as
well as, uh, inference providers,
and it's nice to be able to go here and consider,
you know, top intelligence,
uh, and price or latency or whatever
your, uh,
metrics you care most about,
um,
side by side to kind of quickly evaluate what's
the one that I might care about.
Uh, they also provide this capability to do both X
and Y axis.
Find kind of the, the sweet spot quadrant where
you've got, um, you know,
optimal price, uh, to intelligence
ratios.
Uh, in this example we see a few of our bedrock models,
uh, Claude Haiku,
Deep Seek, as well as the GPT OSS models
really standing out in, uh, really high intelligence,
uh, but, but really considerably lower
prices. So,
uh, important to take note of that.
I think the other thing I wanna make sure that we call out is
that within uh benchmarks
often we talk about just a single kind of
combined intelligence score which is really valuable
for rapid comparison
but there are really detailed benchmarks and if
you know you have something in your use case that's
relevant for example long context
reasoning
uh. That's something that's really relevant
in this use case we're talking about. You can look at specific
benchmarks for that. In this case we've got Claude,
uh, standing out alongside Deep Seek,
uh, as some really good contenders for long context
reasoning capabilities.
This is also a an agentic
application. So, um,
I, I've highlighted here as well, uh, you
know, we've got agentic tool use listed. This is an artificial
analysis resource here,
but Galileo is another agent leaderboard that's
available. It's also Berkeley,
uh, within Agenic.
Leader boards you've got some,
uh, a lot of variety, you know how is
it as an orchestration or managing level
model and how is it as kind of an executor,
uh, worker, uh, model? How is the tool
use selection?
There's a lot of meaningful
benchmarks that are available when you're trying to pick
out the models and which role they should play within
an agentic application.
So this again filters down to kind
of consider hey what's a couple of top models we should
we should think about
uh modalities done we're thinking about metrics
where does the
price performance or other kind of combined
ratios, what benchmarks are really strong.
I also wanna talk about a few other.
Uh, categories of models, and these
are ones that I decided to highlight because
I'd see a lot of our customers,
uh, drive a lot of success with these.
Uh, there are others, but I really think these are the ones to focus
on. First up is reasoning. Uh, you
know, Deep Sek landed in January.
Uh, there was reasoning models before then, but a lot of
attention, a lot of major model providers,
uh, adopted reasoning models as part of
their even hybrid architecture.
Uh, so there's a lot available, um,
you know, reasoning models can do more complex
step by step roles. Often again playing
that orchestration role can be valuable in agentic
use cases.
They can explain the rationale,
very, uh, useful,
uh, when you need to kind of understand why
the, the model made a choice. Uh, traceability,
uh, is very, very nice to have through that
method, of course, science, math, and coding.
Within this category we have a variety available.
The cloud models are good examples.
The GPT OSS models. We've got models
from Deep Seek from Quinn,
and a number of others that are all, uh, reasoning
models. Again,
agentic, uh, you know, autonomous task completion,
very exciting. I think the best practices are being
developed, new offerings are being developed every day,
uh, and.
These are important to consider, you know, what's the tool
selection capabilities, orchestration of multiple,
uh, tools, uh, all the rest there.
Customization is worth, uh, kind of pausing and
considering as well. This tends to be dominated by
open weight models. There are some abilities
to customize proprietary models,
but this is the category where we see the most popularity
for open weight models where the, uh, models
can be used to
fine tune. And the, I'll say from
our experience we're seeing customers
fine tune when they have a very specific performance
requirement they're having a hard time hitting in any other
way. Nothing off the shelf is getting them.
Uh, to the goal they need, and often it's latency
sensitive. So if you have a user experience
that requires a really quick
model response time, uh,
often we'll, we'll see a customer take a
smaller model,
distill from a larger, or really have a very specific
use case.
We're also seeing this grow in gentic applications.
So if you've got a worker
model that does a very specific task every
time, you can fine tune a model and get really
strong results
hitting the latency and cost needs that you might
require. So it's
worth considering these open weight models, these customizable
models as a candidate in your first identification
stage
in case you need to,
uh, fine tune or want to have the option to fine tune
later, uh, and we're seeing this also within
a specific domain. Terminology may be relevant.
And last, this domain specificity. This is
something that's important.
Uh, we're seeing a lot of models
develop in this, uh,
space. This, uh, I'd say finance,
healthcare are two that really stand out.
Um,
this is, uh, driving more success if
you have specific domains where the language is
very relevant for that domain, you can
sometimes get higher performance, higher intelligence in the model
itself, uh.
You know, Bedrock Marketplace has a lot of offerings
in this,
uh, area. Uh, a couple
examples. Upstage is a really good model for
Korean language translation.
Uh, there's also
from writer there's a Palmyra, uh, financial
model as well as a healthcare model.
So a few to consider, uh, as
additional options to,
um, that maybe if your, if your domain
has some offering in that space.
So back to our use case,
let's look at the financial crimes investigation agent.
Um, first step there, filter by modality.
We just, these are just text problems that we're solving
right now. So text to text,
document analysis summarization.
Um, we'd wanna look at those benchmarks. We, we considered
summarization specifically long context reasoning,
uh, some of these agentic capabilities
as well, uh,
down to the differentiated capabilities, and then I think it would
be in this case because of the financial crimes
there's some terminology we probably wanna include a customizable
model as well.
So that gives us a result, right? We're kinda going from
all the models in the world down to a short list that we
think could be really strong for this. This would
include Cloud Sonnet,
OpenAI, uh, GPTOSS in this
case, and Deepeek
V3.1. So,
uh, that's the identify stage.
Uh, I'm gonna now hand off to my colleague John
Liu who's gonna talk through evaluation and optimization.
Thank you.
All right,
so now we get to go into
the evaluation stage,
and when it comes to evaluation,
as Scott mentioned earlier, it's
important to have a framework in place to do this, right?
Some of our customers have put in place frameworks
that let them evaluate a model and
decide whether they want to include that in their production workload
within 24 to 48 hours,
and today we're gonna present a framework that'll help
you hopefully set something similar in
place. When it comes to evaluation,
the first step is always create your golden data set,
which is that source of truth that you wanna benchmark
all your models that you're trying
against to see how well it performs.
And then when you benchmark these models, you want
to make sure you're continuously benchmarking
the models because even if you don't change
the model themselves,
the incoming context might change
which could lead to unexpected results.
So let's go into our sample
golden data set and see what that actually is
about. The golden
this data set is really just made up of two pieces,
right? One
is going to be the prompt.
In this case,
it describes out a particular use case we
want to measure in our financial crimes agent.
And the second part
is the source of truth.
This is
why we call it the golden data set, the ground truth.
This is what you want to measure
your the models that you want to try against
and see how close they come to
this source of truth.
When you create a golden data set, first you
start with the basics. You want to have a
comprehensive data set, about 100 use
cases, right, of which,
you know, you wanna choose. They're very specific
to your particular terminology,
the way that you're thinking of designing your workflow,
because only by creating this
tailored data set
do you know whether the model that you selected
is going to be useful for you, right? The,
the. The generic benchmarks that Scott
presented first,
they're a very good starting point, but you want to
see how much of that actually translates to the
use case you have in mind.
You also don't wanna just live in what we call the
easy mode, right? You don't, you wanna also
select cases that are adversarial, right?
You wanna trip up the models because you're trying to
define
where the limits of your model is going to
be. And typically
these adversarial use cases, these tricky use
cases, they make up about 5%
of the 100 use cases that I mentioned earlier.
And a good way to start,
you set up 10 use cases
and then you get an internal feedback loop
with your subject matter experts and build that up
to 100.
But then as you're rolling out the production, you're introducing
more models you're now thinking about 200-300
use cases and
potentially there's a better way to scale these golden
data sets than continuously lean
on human resources, right? Subject matter
experts are expensive.
So let's take a look if we can do that.
What humans are not so
great at or not very efficient at doing,
you know, is all these detailed tasks,
right, these detailed low level tasks
or trying to create multiple iterations
of data sets
or reading detailed SOPs, standard
operating procedures, and translating that
and making sure that's captured in your golden data set.
We can do it,
but it's not efficient.
And what humans are quite good at doing, a
good use of our
intuition, right,
is the high level judgment that we have.
And we're also quite good
at looking at total frameworks
and seeing hey what works well and what
doesn't work well.
So you see here there are 3 things
high level judgment,
setting rules and standards through rubrics,
and then looking for ways to improve solutions.
So if there's a way that we can leverage the
strength of humans
and then delegate we're called the low level
tasks to agents,
then we've got a pretty good solution to help us scale
our golden data set from that 100 to the
200, 300 type of use cases.
And now let's look what that actually looks like.
We start with
the first agent, right? This is the
user simulator,
and this you can think of that is actually the KYC
expert. He's doing work
to find out whether there's a potential
financial crime associated or fraudulent
detection,
fraudulent activity associated with this,
uh, particular transaction.
You have a very descriptive mission
for the agent and a persona and
then some example questions
because the more descriptive you are
with your agents, the more accurate they're going
to be. You
pair this user simulator with
your task agent,
and this is the agent that actually goes through and does
all the work, you know, looks through all the documents,
looks through the
online offline credit cards, for example,
synthesize that information and comes
back with a recommendation to the user
saying, hey, is this a fraudulent or
not fraudulent activity?
Here you can see again mission persona
described and they have an action
they have tool calls because they're actually going
through and pulling in this information.
Finally, you pair this with the critique
agent,
and this is the actual
um agent that looks through
how close the task agent is
or how well the task agent performs
against a set of rubrics or rules
that the subject matter expert, the human,
set in place earlier.
Here you see the mission and your job is
to go and evaluate the task agent, make sure it does a
good job, and your persona, you're an expert
teacher and you've got some tools
as well. Your, your actions are, you
have some global rec global like evaluation
methods, and you have some relative evaluation
methods that you call dynamically
when you're actually evaluating the task agent
itself. Let's
put that together
We have our user simulator agent.
It passed through a request over to the
task agent.
Now paired with this of course is our critique agent
which is reading rules from this rubric that was
defined by the humans.
The critique agent
continuously iterates what the results
are from the task agent
until the critique agent says yes.
The response that you gave meets the
rubrics that were set in place,
and at that point,
the critique agent of course passes the correct answer
back to
the, the task agent, and the task agent now
sends it to user simulator, but also the critique
critique agent passes that to the golden
data set. So now you're automatically scaling your
golden data set.
Now where's the human,
right? The human
is actually evaluating this entire system
at this time, right? They're not in the detailed
weeds of like looking at every single one of these,
these, um, responses. They look at how
the overall framework behaves, and
they can make suggestions that says how can I
improve how the critique agent is actually
guiding the task agent. Maybe we
need to have more tables that are coming
through so it's easier for
our, our cus our customers to
read. So they update the rubric
and now this entire golden disk set
gets stronger and the rubric gets stronger
as well.
Now to build this,
customers can benefit from AWS's
Agentic stack.
Customers can start with the open source
framework strands and very
quickly build, deploy locally
agents.
And as they're ready to scale,
they can now lean on agent core
and benefit from enterprise grade
security and also dedicated runtime
environments and memory management
and there were lots of announcements this reinvents
around our agent core.
So we've gone through,
we've created our golden data set.
Now we get into the metrics that we want to evaluate
against. The operational metrics
are the foundational piece,
cost, latency, and scalability.
Just like almost any software, right?
Um, some things to keep in mind, of course, is
when you're actually measuring these operational
metrics, make sure you're sending in inference
requests that cover a variety
of, um, patterns, right? You wanna look
for your P95, your P99
type of response context window lens so
you can find out
what the latency is, and you also want
to send a variety of different workloads
so you can see where the model or the model serving
solution you're using
runs into errors.
Once you have your
operational metrics covered, you can move into
the comprehensive evaluation metrics
around semantics knowledge, right?
So you've probably seen
the quality and accuracy, the style and usability,
responsible AI. This is
pretty much again,
um, ground.
Foundational aspects that customers are
now used to.
However, as customers have been rolling these
into production over the last year, they've
also introduced their own custom metrics,
because what these custom metrics actually
measure, just like any software, there are
KPIs that you wanna bring in. For example,
it could be click through rates of a
particular task you wanna get done,
or it could be, you know, the
type of overrides any time a, a
particular user decides to override what the agent does,
maybe that's another KPI you wanna bring in.
So keep these in mind as
you're evaluating your model. Don't just
lean on the
tried and true quality and accuracy. These are important,
but bring in the actual custom metrics from your
workload as well.
Some other metrics to keep in mind,
and, you know, it's a temporal consistency I mentioned a little
bit earlier, you have to consistently look
and evaluate your model. You don't wanna make sure you want tech
model drift early on.
And as you're introducing more modalities,
you wanna make sure you're measuring the modality not just
in isolation but also as they interact
with each other.
And finally agentic capabilities, right? How
well is your entire system or
your entire model behaving when it's calling
tools or when it's actually orchestrating across
different agents.
So we've gone through, we've got our metrics.
Let's look at what methods are used to
evaluate
these models
and really break down into 3,
right. We start with the benchmarks,
the programmatic
type of evaluations,
and these are really good when it has like a true
right or wrong answer. You can think of, uh,
benchmarks like the MMLU,
which measures how good a model
behaves for translation, or you could
GM 8 SK, which measures how good
a model is for mathematic calculations,
right? Very good starting point.
But if you wanna pick up the nuances of
like summarization or how people talk,
how people think, right, then you start leaning
on humans, right? That's this is where human
evaluation comes in. Your subject matters have
to come in and look for those nuanced
semantic type of evaluation.
Now to help us scale
we can now lean on
models as well because they've got much deeper
reasoning capabilities that's been developed over
the last year. So customers are now using
powerful models whether it's a single powerful
model as a judge to evaluate the output of
other models, or they put in
place
maybe 10 to 12 lightweight models
and as as a jury evaluate
the output of the model that's being
evaluated.
Amazon Bedrock model evaluation supports all
three of these, right? We've got our programmatic
evaluation,
the human evaluation, and also
LM is a judge.
Importantly,
we also support custom metrics.
And if you want to evaluate
models that are not directly within Bedrock,
you can do that too. You can bring the responses
from those models and run them through Amazon
Bedrock model evaluation.
So let's dive a little bit under EM as
a judge because that's what we're gonna use for our
financial crimes agent that we've been using
as our reference case.
Under the hood, what actually happens is
we've optimized the prompts
for a variety, a variety of our evaluator
models which include the anthropic models,
some of the meta models, and Nova models
as well.
We tell it how to behave
and we tell it what type of response to give.
And what gets passed in is the Jason
online file of
the golden data set, right? Here's all my prompts,
here's my reference answer, and
here's also the response from
the model that you're gonna evaluate against.
And to set this up with Amazon
Bedrock model evaluation,
you start with selecting the models. There are two
things you want to select
the model you want to be the evaluator.
And the model you want to evaluate in this
case we're picking the Sona 37
as the evaluator and then we're gonna evaluate the GPTOS
120B.
You select the metrics, right?
Um, Amazon Bedrock model evaluation has
12 metrics, and of course you can also
import your custom metrics as mentioned earlier.
And now you run
the model evaluation
and you get a result and you can compare different models
against each other. In this case I've run a simple evaluation
against the GPT OSS as mentioned earlier and
also Deep Seek V3.1,
and you can see a radar chart of how well
they perform.
You can dive deep a little bit as well, like
into each of the prompts that you're evaluating,
it gives you a score. Did it
from 0 to 1, or 1 being the best score.
And if I want to dive in and understand
why I got a score as such, I can do that too.
I click in and it have an explanation.
In this case it got a one because guess
what? The valdo that you're evaluating
matched very well
with the ground truth that you actually gave in.
Now we can move into the optimized
state, and we've gone through, we've evaluated,
we have a set of models that we want to choose against.
And when we think about optimizing,
we wanna start by thinking it's not just optimizing
a single model, you optimize the entire
system,
so you can choose single models to
replace and you can also introduce multiple
models you can optimize the entire end
to end workflow.
You can further customize individual models
through fine tuning and distillation
and then you can optimize how you're sending your inference
requests for cost and latency
as an example,
you know, we announced.
The inference tiers
that was in today's
today's the Dave Brown keynote actually he's talking
about the inference tiers around that
and there that's where you actually
pay a little premium, for example, to
access the priority tiers to make sure that your inference
are at the top of the line
or you maybe for the less time sensitive
ones you can pay up to a 50% discount
and use the flex tier, and this is how
you start optimizing
cost and versus the kind of latency.
And when it comes to optimizing these multiple
models, you have to consider the routing strategies
you have, and they're really just 4 things
I'd like to share with you today.
You can start with rule-based routing. You can
go through, look at the queries,
single, simple queries, use light model,
complex queries, use the heavier models. Private
queries, if it's highly sensitive ones, and
maybe I wanna use a model that I'm hosting
myself. But that
has a challenge too. This means that someone's
always writing these rules,
so we can benefit from machine learning
based routing
using classic machine learning. You can train classifiers
around the data set that you have and then route
these incoming inference requests to the proper model.
Of course the challenge there is you need a training data
set. So
you can further benefit
from using the LLMs themselves, right? The
LMs themselves can look at the incoming data and say,
well, based on this, we think the profile matches,
we should send it to what type of model light,
medium, heavy.
And then you can further fine tune that as
you get more data.
The best way, of course, combine all three of them,
right, that gives you a very robust way to route
these inference requests to the different models.
When you look at the individual models themselves,
you can customize them through a variety of methods
through Amazon Bedrock.
You can do straight fine tuning
and you can also do distillation
where you take a teacher model and then
bring the knowledge of that
into a lighter model,
or you can do some advanced
customization on your own through maybe SageMaker
and bring those models into Bedrock
through Amazon Bedrock's custom model import.
And we just announced Nova Forge,
um, about two days ago, and that further
helps customers customize their
models because now
you can not just benefit from
your own data set, you can benefit from
Nova's pre-trained data set as well. You can
bring these two data sets together and train the
models. So
looking at our financial crimes
investigation agent after these two steps, what are we looking
at? Well, we've got the GBTOSS
120 for fast classification tasks,
and then now we've got the sonnet for the complex analysis
and we fine tuned the
GBTOSS model
and then we optimize our inference through the different
inference tiers that I mentioned, which leads us
to an 80% reduction
while scaling the workload from 500 million inference
requests to 5 billion per day.
And we've not talked about
the customer behind this, but this is a real customer use
case that we've seen in production.
Benefiting from
model choice, the optimizations,
the framework that we've talked about so far.
Now let's review and just put it all together.
In our three step framework in action,
we start with the identify state.
You have a library of models that you wanna look at.
You review the general benchmarks that are out there,
the modalities,
and then you select from there
the models you want and you evaluate these models
against your specific use case, against the
golden data set that you've created.
You then optimize the setup that
you have and you can have single model
type of workloads you can have multiple model type
of workloads.
And importantly, you wanna get all this
information and bring that feedback so you can
improve your particular framework,
including monitoring for latency, cost,
and accuracy.
And also
getting the real-time user feedback
and having that information improve that
golden data set.
Another benefit of having a strong golden data
set doesn't just power up the model evaluation
that you have,
you can also use it to fine tune
models,
so you get almost like 2 for the price of 1.
And that's how this 3 step framework works. You
put something like this in place,
you can
be able to evaluate a model for your
workload within 24 to 48 hours
of it dropping.
So with that said, I'd like to bring
on Brian who can show you how Coin
Market Cap has done
similar type of framework
and enabled Gen AI workloads
for millions of users daily.
Thanks, John.
Hi everyone. My name is Brian and I manage AI
products in Coin Market Cap.
In the next roughly 20 minutes, I'll be walking
you through how
CoinMarket Cap selects models.
The analogy I like to use is,
although you can use an F1 car to
deliver groceries, you wouldn't want to do that.
You can use the strongest models, the most
advanced models to do the simplest task.
You wouldn't want to do that for different reasons,
cost being one of them.
Before I continue, how many of you know about CoinMticcap?
OK. Not many,
not many people here know about CoinMarchitect.
So this slide will be useful.
Coin Market Cap is a cryptocurrency data
platform and
we've been around since 2013.
For reference, Bitcoin,
one Bitcoin at that time cost roughly $100.
When I checked this morning, a Bitcoin was roughly
$93,000.
But more than a decade later, we're at the home of crypto
with over 65 million active monthly
active users and more than 1 billion
page views.
If you're more if you're more familiar with traditional finance, we're
often referred to as the Bloomberg of crypto.
We have more than 1 million API users
with institutions like Google, Yahoo
Finance,
Coinbase, and central banks around the world using
our crypto data.
Our gen AI
journey started in Q3 2023,
and since then, we have more than 10
user facing products in production.
Our AI products are used by millions around
the world, and
since 2023, we have consumed trillions
of LLM tokens, and today,
we consume more than 10 billion LLM
tokens every single day.
This scale is exactly why we are rigorous
about our model selection
and why Amazon Bedrock matters in our stack.
So, what do we use these more than
10 billion tokens for every single day?
Four main things.
First,
users come to our site to find alphas,
to find signals.
With more than 27 million cryptocurrencies
tracked by coin market cap and thousands
more created every single day,
there is a lot of noise.
LLM compresses this noise into
signals and users use
our AI products to find these
signals.
Second,
explain. Users come to our site to
try to understand why did, why is Bitcoin
price up, why is Bitcoin price down, what
is Bitcoin, what is proof of work,
and as we all know, AI does a
great job explaining all of these.
Third, forecasts.
Users want price predictions so that they can make
money. They want
potential scenarios and
although nobody has a crystal ball, AI can help
lay out those options and give reasoning behind
each of them.
4th,
act. Insight is only useful
if you can act on it.
We turn AI outputs into watchlists,
alerts and automations, so users can
act on these insights.
Let me show you one of our use cases, what
we call CMCAI.
This is essentially a chatbot. So imagine,
You wake up one day, like today, Bitcoin
is up and you, you wonder why Bitcoin
is up.
Instead of having to open 10 different tabs,
you just go to CMC and ask
CMC AI.
Using live crypto data, on chain
data, and social sentiment data,
it gives you an answer.
And then you, you're wondering,
you read about this hack that just happened and you're
wondering why did it happen.
Instead of having to deep dive into
many news articles, many social posts, you just
ask CMCAI.
And of course,
this experience is also on our app.
Millions of users use CMC's
portfolio feature to track their portfolio
and because we have this data, we
can personalize the answers for users.
The same question by a different user would
yield different results,
personalized results.
Of course, we didn't start from that chatbot that
you just saw.
Back in 2023,
we, when we started our AI journey, our aim
was to minimize risk and maximize
learning.
We needed 22 critical components
before we scale to the AI chatbot.
First is stakeholder buy-in, and
the second is a deep understanding on
how to build on top of the non-deterministic
nature of LLMs.
The image you see on the screen is
AIFEQs, one of our earlier products.
And when we, when creating this AIFEQs,
the reason we chose this is because it's on a less trafficked
part of the page,
so the risk is lower and whenever,
for all the AIFEQs we generate, a
human would thoroughly review them to make
sure that it is correct, it is accurate
before we go, go live with them.
And this manual review process, although,
although tedious and although it took a long time,
it was
very important because we learned the limitations
and strengths of LLMs.
With this product, we,
and with more organization,
organizational buying over time,
we build AI products are more prominent
part of, parts of our product and more deeply
integrated AI within our product.
So, as we moved from simple use
cases like AI FAQs to what we have
now, which is the AI chatbot and many other integrations
across the site,
one thing we realized is that
we cannot have the same model do many different
tasks.
The example I gave earlier is you don't want to use an F1
car to deliver groceries, and I'll give another
analogy.
In an F1 pit crew, you have different
people for different tasks and speed
and efficiency
comes because of that specialization.
I'll highlight 5 different tasks that we do
within CMC using AI.
First, a sentiment extractor. Every
day, we process millions of social
posts, millions of news articles.
And in order, and we want to extract
the sentiment
within these social posts and news articles.
Is it positive? Is it very positive,
or is it the opposite?
The LLM we select here needs to be cheap
because I just mentioned the scale. We process millions
of social posts and news articles,
and it needs to be fast.
So, the most advanced models typically don't do,
typically don't suit this that well.
The second is planning.
This is about taking the user's query, however
complex or ambiguous,
and transforming them into a list of to do lists.
This LLM needs to be very good at reasoning
and understanding a user's query
and converting that into a to do list.
The third is data retrieval.
This is about taking the data,
the, the to do list from the 2nd step and
converting that into a list of tool calls.
What are tools? Tools that you can think of tools
as API calls that LLMs
can make in order to retrieve context.
This is context, this context can be the latest
data, the latest news that the LLM
doesn't have access to within its training data.
This the model that we select here needs
to be good at choosing the right tools
and the right parameters within those tools.
The fourth is summarization.
Now that we have retrieved all that data
for the large language model,
this large in this step, the
LLM needs to take hundreds of pages of
data and news articles and convert
that into one single page of data for the user
to read. And the 5th is
translating natural language into
CMCIDs
because we track more than 27 million
cryptocurrencies
with the same name can represent many different cryptocurrencies.
What we found here is that we don't
need the strongest model to do this conversion.
A simple chat model generally works very
good for this.
How do, so we, we care about three main
things when selecting models for the,
the different use cases I mentioned earlier.
One is quality.
Quality looks different for each use case.
So, metrics like factual
accuracy, relevance,
proper evidence usage, groundedness
matter to us depending on the use case.
Second is speed.
Time to first token,
time tokens per second, and time to last
token matters a lot to us.
And the third is cost efficiency.
We don't care about, we don't care
very much about the raw token, raw
cost per token.
What we care more about is the cost to quality ratio.
So, with so many models coming out, I think
Scott previously shared that there are,
there's one model coming out every 10 seconds.
How do we choose which models to test? We can't,
we can't possibly test
every single model every 10 seconds.
So, in CMC we have 3 main
categories of models.
The first,
at least the way we think about it, there are 3 main categories of models.
The first is full reasoning.
These are your top tier models. They are very good
at complex tasks.
Using the cloud family of models as
examples in this slide,
this would be your
Sonnet 4.5 and your Opus 4.5.
Under the light reasoning models, these are mid-tier
models deal with reasoning and are
generally faster and more cost efficient.
This would be your Haiku 4.5.
And then the third,
fast and low cost, these are lightweight models, typically
chat models without any reasoning
that are used for simple and high volume tasks.
This would be your Haiku 3.5.
John talked quite a bit about golden data set
and that's what I'm gonna be talking about within this slide.
So, in order to prepare the golden data
set, we always start by setting the scope.
We need to make clear what is being tested and
with over the next couple of slides, we will use
to calling to as an example.
If a model has access to 10
tools, we want to make sure that it is calling
the right tools to retrieve the right data
to generate the answer for the users.
Say a user's query only requires 2 of the
tools because it doesn't need that much data.
The model should not go and fetch data
from 5 of the tools
and be excessive about 2 calling.
So, that is the scope,
2 calling accuracy.
The second is ground truth.
Humans will prepare the golden data set.
Say we have 1000 user queries that we know
users care about.
For each of these user queries, we will,
we will think about, hey, which tool
do you need to call to retrieve the data to answer
the question.
So, say for question one, we select 4 different
tools, that is the ground truth.
Third step is we run checks.
We call the LLM API and we give
it the 10 tools and we see what it actually
returns to us.
Then we compare what they returned to us
with our ground truth.
If the LLM selected 4 tools, when
our ground truth has 2 tools,
then we know something is wrong.
There are 3 metrics we care about here, precision,
recall, and F1, and I'll talk more
about these shortly.
And the last is update. This step is super important.
Your ground truth will shift over
time. Your ground truth needs to
reflect what users care about and what
your users care about changes over time.
So, using the same set of 1000
questions, maybe 100 of 1000
questions will not matter 3 months from now.
So, you need to remove those 3 100
questions and change it with something new.
Let's dive a bit deeper into tool use.
Precision is the first metric we care about,
and what it tells us is
amongst the tools that the model actually
called, how many of them were correct,
how many of them were necessary.
Recall tells us out of all
the tools the models should have called,
how many did it indeed call.
And F1 score combines both of them.
So, F1 score is essentially a formula between the
two of them and it's what we use to compare between
models. And the reason why F1 score
is important is because,
say there are 10 tools and the
model calls all 10 tools.
In this case, recall is full
because it called all the tools it needed to call.
However,
precision is extremely low, and the F1
score will reflect that.
So, if model A has an
F1 score of 0.7 and model
B has the F1 score of 0.4,
then model A is better and we will choose that
for the two calling use case.
Let's dive into another use case, summarization.
Summarization, like I mentioned earlier, is about taking
hundreds of pages of content and
converting that into a single page or maybe two pages
of content for the user to read.
The model needs to have very good ability
to understand large context,
and there are a few, there are many different metrics we care about here. I'll
mention 4.
1st, is the answer relevant to the
user's question.
2,
is it readable? 3,
is the answer well structured?
And 4,
groundedness. Is the final answer
grounded in the context it was provided?
We all know LLMs hallucinate. So, what
we found is that sometimes
LLMs in the final answer will come up with
facts that we did not provide it within the context
and groundedness is super important.
The chart you see
is our is our test of
seven different LLMs for
groundedness.
The orange line represents median,
the box represents the inter quartile range,
which means the 50% the the
middle 50% of the results, and the
dots represent outliers.
You see that the first result has a
tight inter quoile range and a decent
median score.
The second result has a very
big inter quota range and
the highest median result, so it has the potential
for the highest result and it has also potential
for low results.
And then the other, all the other results just are generally
not so good
looking metrics.
So, in this particular test, we
selected model one because although
model 2 had a
potential for very good results,
it was too unpredictable. So, we cannot
go with that.
Internally, we have this system called GLAS,
which stands for
generic LLM as a Judge evaluation Service.
What this does is it allows us to use
LLM as judge very easily. It
allows any team member to
call LLM as judge and to get the results
in hours instead of in days.
And if anybody wants to use LLM as a
judge internally,
the main thing they have to do is to define the JSON
input.
They define the goal
of the test, they define the dimensions
that they care about, and they define the candidates
that they are testing.
After they have this JSON input, they simply call the
API
and underneath the hood of the API we
actually call many different leading models, and
all of these models combined together to
produce a PDF output that contains
charts like what you saw earlier,
and also AI insights.
Using these AI insights combined
with more human evaluation,
we can decide which model is good
for the job.
Model evaluation is not a one-off
event. New models come out very frequently,
and there are typically 32 triggers
that make us want to
do a model evaluation.
One is a product insight,
second is a new model coming out that we think it's worth
testing. The first step of
model evaluation is always human evaluation.
A lot of models get filtered out
simply in this step.
So, humans, our team,
myself or my colleagues will go in and test the
model on a few important use cases.
If it passes this stage, we will run the
glass system, which is what I mentioned in the previous slide.
And then combined with AI insights and
more human evaluation,
we will know whether this model is suitable for
the use case,
and if it's suitable, we will push it to production.
In production,
every single answer.
is run through an LLMS judge.
So we know the quality of all answers generated
in production and we have alerts
if something goes wrong.
This step is very important because we have gained many
insights just from this step.
Of course, I need to have a slide talking about how
amazing AWS and Amazon Bedrock is
and to be fair,
they have been great partners. So,
I think they fully deserve this.
The first is inference.
Many models in the latest models
are all available on on Amazon Bedrock.
Whenever Claude come comes out with a new model,
Amazon Bedrock has it the same day.
To us,
calling LLM APIs is
just an LLM APIs. We don't deal with infra,
we don't deal with scaling,
and we are very grateful for that.
So, That's, that's
the main thing that AWS Bedrock helps us with.
Amazon Bedrock helps, helps us with.
The second thing is rack. We use Amazon's
open search service and their coherent with ranker.
This helps us to fetch the right content
for the model to use to answer the user's question.
The 3rd is security. Built-in
features like zero data retention is super
important because we process
the portfolio data of millions of users.
So we need to have this for our, for our inference
provider.
And the 4th is hands-on partnership.
Since the beginning,
Amazon hasn't been just an
influence provider. They have always been very helpful,
offering deep technical support and
in fact, we are working together on, on a crypto
AI benchmark and this benchmark will
compare general purpose chatbots
with CMC AI's ability for
crypto use cases.
So, to sum, to sum up,
4 points.
First is the use case drives
model choice.
The best model, a Ferrari car,
isn't always suitable for every job, isn't
always suitable for delivering groceries.
Specialists
usually beats generalists for for
different use cases.
The second
is that evaluation is not a
side project. It is a product.
It's never set and forget and
through continuous evaluation,
can you then can you convert
what may be a fun demo into a production-ready
product. The third is
humans matter. As much as we try
to automate everything away,
what we found is that humans
alone or humans combined with AI brings us
the best insights.
And the 4th is the right partner multiplies
output.
A AWS has been super helpful. Amazon
Bedrock has been super helpful, and
you need to pick the right inference partners.
What's next for CMC?
There are three things that we,
we, we will be focusing on in 2026. The
first is reducing the cost of inference
and the speed of inference.
And there are a couple of ways we are thinking of doing this.
First is through fine tuning models for
different use cases, and the second is
model distillation model distillation, which
is available on Amazon Bedrock.
The second is B2B opportunities.
So, many enterprises have indicated interest
in integrating AI within their products,
and instead of building it from the ground up,
they come to us and ask us for it.
So, if any of you are in crypto and you want it,
reach out to me.
And the third is better AI UX
and expanded CMC AI capabilities.
Users mainly interact with large language
models through a chat interface right now, and
in order to get the best from that,
users need to be expert prompters and
they need to be, they need to understand the limitations
of a chat interface.
I don't think that is the future of AI
and I think that that AI needs to be more proactive,
it needs to be easier to use, it needs to be more
personalized, and that's what we will be focusing
on in 2026.
So I hope
now 20 minutes later you are better at choosing
models
and if any of you are in crypto, try
out CMC AI and let me know what you think.
I'll hand the time back to Scott.
Thank you so much, Brian. Uh, the work
that Brian and his teams are doing is
really fantastic, uh,
exciting to see the level of maturity and
the scale of production they're working at.
I really appreciate you sharing all that with our audience
today. Uh, quick recap, uh,
we've got, uh, just, you know, wanted to kind of
reconsider what we talked about today.
Uh, 3 steps identifying,
uh, models,
look at the general benchmarks, consider modalities,
and pick good candidate models that are relevant
for your use case.
Uh, next step is evaluate,
run those models in your environment, uh,
on your data,
on your use case, and, and, and generate that golden
data set so that you can,
uh, verify and know that you're picking the right models for
your use case.
And then optimize
uh those models through model combinations
or through fine tuning to make sure that you're achieving
uh the benchmarks
in the performance requirements that you need and
uh great to hear uh from
Coin Maret Cap as well
to understand what that looks like in production uh
for them today.
I wanna close with a few uh
resources that I think could be helpful for you all.
The first is an article written by
one of our VPs talking about the value of
model choice,
nice kind of general purpose,
uh, explanation of why we're committed
to that at Amazon Bedrock.
We've also got a model
choice page for the Amazon Bedrock
website. On that is all those
new models we launched, uh, 18 new
models,
uh, in the openweight category to over 20.
Uh, this week and, uh,
we've also got those new model providers, so
lots more coming, uh, we, uh,
keep stay tuned, keep watching more models are on the way.
Uh, we've also got
a few GitHub resources. There's a model evaluation
application. This is downloadable. You can run it locally
in tandem with the Bedrock tools for
evaluation. This is one that you can use,
uh, generates a nice visual, just a streamlet
application. That you can compare, uh, you
know, intelligence as well as accuracy,
uh, latency,
performance side by side. It's a nice one to
kinda share with stakeholders, help them understand why you're
picking the model you're picking
and then if you wanna go even further, there's a model evaluation
workshop available also on GitHub. So
take a shot of those, uh, great resources
to, uh, get whatever level you want to
kinda understand,
uh, what's available
within Amazon Bedrock.
I wanna thank you all for being here. Uh,
it was, uh, great getting to talk through this with you.
There is a
little uh survey if you, if you don't mind
filling that out, that does help us out. We do read
those surveys.
We're really committed to trying to
uh deliver great presentations for you all.
Uh,
thank you again for being here today and enjoy the rest
of reinvent.